اضخم جبل جليدي يدخل قبره الاخير
رعب في العالم بعد انفصال هذه الكتله
العملاقه التي قد يغطي حجمها ومساحتها
مدنا باكملها
كارثه اخرى تضاف لقائمه ازمات المناخ التي
لا تتوقف بسبب الاحتباس الحراري كل هذا
يحدث والكثافه السكانيه على كوكبنا في
ازدياد مستمر وصلت الى 8 مليارات نسمه منذ
ايام ما يعني مزيدا من الانشطه البشريه
والتلوث وانبعثت الغازات الدفيئه وبالتالي
مزيدا من الاحتباس الحراري هو القادم ربما
لا ينظر بخير
لنبدا من هنا من القاره القطبيه الجنوبيه
منذ انطلاق الثوره الصناعيه ارتفعت حراره
كوكب الارض باكثر من درجه مئويه وفي مارس
من عام 2021 التقط الباحثون هذه الصوره
التي تعبر عن واقع الماساوي القادم لا
محاله اعلن رسميا عن انفصال هذا اللوح
الجليدي ايه 76 عن جرف رونو الجليدي في
القاره القطبيه الجنوبيه هذه القطعه
الجليديه قدرت مساحتها انا ذاك باكثر من
4000 و300 كلم مربع اكبر جبل جليد في
العالم
لقد تفوق على هذا الجبل اي 23 اي لكن
الخطر هنا هو تحطم هذه القطعه وانقسامها
الى ثلاثه اجزاء الجزء الاكبر من هذا
الجبل ايه 76 ايه انفصل عن اللوح الام منذ
ايام قليله ودخل ممر دريك الخطير متجها
لقبره الماء الاخيره
فبحسب موقع لايف ساينس العلمي فان طول هذا
اللوح الجليدي العملاق ايه 76 ايه يبلغ
135 كلم في حين يصل عرضه الى 26 كلم وعند
دخوله ممر دريك المائي يتم جره سريعا
باتجاه الشرق ثم يرسل شمالا لمياه اكثر
دفئا وعند هذه اللحظه يذوب تماما
ما قد يحول مليارات الاطنان من المياه
العذبه باتجاه المحيط الامر الذي يشكل
تهديدا على الحياه البحريه بالاضافه الى
ان فقدان اجزاء اخرى من الجرف الجليدي
يساهم بشكل غير مباشر في ارتفاع منسوب
مياه البحار ما قد يؤدي الى غرق مدن
ساحليه باكملها
القاره القطبيه الجنوبيه ترتفع درجه
حرارتها بوتيره اسرع من بقيه الكوكب وهي
تحتوي على ما يكفي من المياه المجمده لرفع
مستوى سطح البحر العالمي بمقدار 60 مترا
لكن بعض العلماء الاكثر تفاعلا يؤكدونا ان
المنطقه التي انفصل منها جبل اي 76 لا
تواجه هذا الاحترار ولا تشكل خطرا في
الوقت الحالي
قد يساهم احترام الهواء والمحيطات في
تسريع هذه الظاهره لكن هذا الجبل الجليدي
تحديدا يبدو جزءا من مسار طبيعي من دون
ارتباط بالتغير المناخي
وبسبب تسارع التغيرات المناخيه اصبحت طقس
اكثر تتطرفا فكل منطقه في العالم طقسا
وتغيرا بيئيا مختلفا نجد حرائق الغابات في
اوروبا وذوبان القمم الجليديه في القطب
الجنوبي واعاصره في امريكا
وسيولا جارفه في الصين وجفافا في
افغانستان والعراق
تلتهم اسرابه اجزاء كبيره من افريقيا
جنوبي الصحراء الكبرى
ومعدلات مرعبه من التلوث تهدد بقاء
الكائنات الحيه
ليبقى السؤال هل هذا الطقس طبيعي ام ان
المناخ اصبح اكثر تتطرفا